hi I'm Erik Bosse and one of the biggest
game changers of Avengers infinity war
was the way it affects the future of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and spoiler
warning if you haven't seen infinity war
yet if half of everyone is dead who's
gonna lead Marvel into its base for
Bruce Banner without Hulk so much
pressure can only make so many movies
about scientific research let's take a
look at how infinity war changed what we
know about Marvel Studios phase 4 and
how the next Avengers movie could launch
us into that next era okay before we get
to phase 4 let's quickly run down where
we're at with phase 3 course infinity
war ended with one of the bleakest
cliffhangers in movie history with half
of the Marvel heroes fading from
existence including many we assume to
lead the next generation of Marvel
movies spider-man black panther the
guardians of the galaxy Doctor Strange
mantas someone we all assumed would
probably get her own trilogy this crisis
can only be resolved in part 2 of this
story Avengers 4 which will officially
end phase 3 a year from now in May 2019
there are two other movies left on the
Phase three calendar ant-man and the
wasp which will come out this July and
Captain Marvel which will come out in
March 2019 I think we can assume both of
these stories to be separate from the
infinity war events at least until the
very ends of those movies
Captain Marvel will be an origin story
set in the 1990s and it looks like
ant-man 2 will take place at least
slightly before infinity war I mean
otherwise you'd think Hank Pym would at
least look a little concerned when he
shrinks down at building into a suitcase
now we've made a few other videos on
this channel about how Avengers 4 could
bring back some of the heroes who faded
away at the end of infinity war and
which characters really deserve to come
back but when you look at what Marvel
has lined up so far for phase 4 that
picture becomes clearer okay so
marblehead Kevin Feige has said that the
studio has up to 20 movies planned for
phase 4 which by the way might not even
be called phase 4 phases 1 2 & 3 really
correspondent to the Avengers Thanos
saga and the next phase could expand the
universe in a whole new way now they've
been pretty tight-lipped about phase 4
but here's what we know as of now the
first film of phase 4 will be the second
spider-man movie the follow-up to
homecoming
Feige said it's gonna start shooting
this summer with homecoming director Jon
Watts we're turning a direct its release
date is currently scheduled as July 5th
2019 just two months after Avengers 4
production is rumored to take place in a
ton of different cities including London
Venice and Prague so Justine's some kind
of globe-trotting adventure and some
fans to speculate
titles like spider-man field trip or
spider-man study-abroad where spider-man
hero trip beyond spider-man all that has
been officially announced are a list of
release dates no movies attached however
it sounds like the one in May 2020 will
be guardians of the galaxy vol 3 writer
director James Gunn has been pretty
vocal about the third movie the
post-credits scene for volume 2 showed
Aisha plotting revenge with a new super
bean in a golden cocoon Adam warlock Sam
actually just made a video explaining
who Adam warlock is and how he could fit
in the MCU now the Russo brothers have
said that Adam warlock will not appear
in Avengers 4 but it sounds like he will
play a big part in guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 Gunn has also said he wants
to explore Rockets origin which he
teased would be even more horrible in
the movies he also said that crag Lin
was doing something important during
infinity war and that he would return
now the next Marvel movie we have
details on is a black widow solo film
now it's not clear when that movie will
come out a few months back we learned
that screenwriter Jack Schaeffer was
hired to work on the script and that
Marvel Studios was meeting with over 65
different directors Kevin Feige is also
said that there will for sure be a black
panther sequel but he has no plans to
rush that movie saying he's willing to
wait until director Ryan Coogler is
ready to work on it and after Doctor
Strange came out in 2016 director scott
derrickson spoke about the possibility
of a sequel with him wanting nightmare
to be the villain but there's no
confirmation on the sequel just yet fans
have also been hopeful that thor
ragnarok could spin off another Thor in
Hulk movie or that we could get a movie
about Nova a character james gunn
actually said in a facebook Q&A that
Marvel is considering Nova is Earth's
representative in the Nova Corps of
xander which yes was just destroyed off
screen in Avengers infinity war but if
other things theory said maybe that
could be reset two bands have also been
pushing for a team-up of all female
Marvel heroes which could include Black
Widow and Scarlet Witch Valkyrie Captain
Marvel Shuri and Ikoyi and others and of
course I'm sure Marvel is also waiting
to see how this whole Disney Fox merger
shakes out it's possible Marvel could
reboot the Fantastic Four and the x-men
in phase 4 in which case all kinds of
great characters and storylines are on
the table Silver Surfer Doctor Doom the
Secret Wars maybe even a reboot of the
Civil War event which was great in the
movie but in the comics it's such a huge
event
anyway they take away from these
announced projects is that we should
have hoped that many of the fallen from
infinity war still have futures
spider-man black panther
to the galaxy and it sounds like Black
Widow will continue to survive we're
looking at some kind of resurrection or
reset and Avengers 4 of course there's
always the possibility that these
announced films won't even feature the
heroes themselves Black Panther sequel
could follow characters like Shuri
Okoye a well kabhi in Baku carrying on
two challahs let me see in some other
way guardians three could just be a side
adventure with rocket and nebula Krag
Lin Asia and a warlock and a new group
growing from the handle of Stormbreaker
spider-man two could just be Ned trying
to fit into Peters old spider-man suit
guys I would watch all of these movies
as much as I loved chadwick boseman and
Tom Holland and Chris Pratt the
supporting characters of the MCU were
perfectly cast but I'm actually curious
to know from you guys if the characters
who faded away at the end of infinity
war stay gone even though I highly doubt
this case which supporting character
survivor would you most want to see take
over the mantle in phase four personally
I want to see a Sheree Black Panther
she's smart she's funny she knows how
the suit works give her her own movie
comment with your thoughts down below or
you can tweet me directly I da boss
they're probably new rock stars on
Twitter for updates on her videos like
and share this video and subscribe to
new rockstars we got a ton of different
videos on infinity war and we're gonna
be talking about this more as we head
into phase four thanks for watching guys
bye